downtown las vegas put on a celebration
for tony shea tonight shea passed away
last november and ever since his death
there has been an outpouring of support
and appreciation for what he's done for
our las vegas community madison
kimbrough joins us live in downtown
where shea's celebration of life event
is currently taking place madison
yes positivity all around here sasha at
the event for shea started around 4 this
afternoon and will last until midnight
locals sharing what impact he made on
their lives and within the downtown las
vegas community
it's always ways to think bigger it
really takes people like that to really
commit to their city you know where they
grew up and stuff like that to really
put the time and effort and money to
just create something for the community
a man known for revitalizing the
downtown area of las vegas former zappos
ceo and entrepreneur tony shea was
honored saturday by the downtown
alliance nothing would be here now if
there wasn't any change and if someone
didn't have the initiative to get up and
do something this is beautiful this is
amazing and i love this and i thank him
so much for this shea who passed away in
november of last year died of smoke
inhalation during a fire at a friend's
house during the thanksgiving holiday
shea remembered as a staple to the vegas
community creating places like container
park a place for people of all ages to
enjoy i've been here for over 17 years
and seeing container park being an empty
lot to becoming what it is it is crazy
to think about shea would have been 48
years old on december 12th the
celebration of his life included an art
and car showcase food trucks galore and
entertainment plus discounts at some of
shea's favorite places i think it's a
good way to remember him
and i think it's also a good way to
remind the people keep going
around 9pm the fremont street experience
aired a one-minute video they produced
celebrating his life
and in that video the song human played
which was one of shea's favorite songs
by the band the killers the entire
tribute was free to the public reporting
live in downtown from fremont street
madison kimbrough live local now